bien nos preguntan la recta numérica
muestra cuando surge y ebro empiezan y
terminan de jugar una partida de ajedrez
aquí está nuestra recta numérica y
podemos observar en verde el punto que
indica cuando comenzaron y el rojo el
punto que indica cuando terminaron a qué
hora empezaron su hora y ebro a jugar
ajedrez a ver observemos la recta
numérica y observamos las marcas indican
de las 5 10 a las 5 15 cada una de las
divisiones equivale a un minuto veamos 5
10 511 5 12 5 13 5 14 que es el que está
indicado y 5 15 el indicado dijimos es 5
14 entonces empiezan a las 5 14 perfecto
a que ahora terminan suran y ebro de
jugar ajedrez ahora observamos que el
punto rojo está entre las 5 40 y las 5
45 y las marcas o divisiones pues siguen
siendo de un minuto entonces es 5 45 41
perfecto terminaron a las 5 con 41
minutos cuánto tiempo jugaron surrach y
ebro ajedrez nos preguntan en minutos
habría varias maneras de hacer esto
observamos que entre las marcas azules
hay 5 minutos va de 5 15 a 5 20 de 5 20
a 5 25 entonces podríamos hacer 5 10 15
20 25 y después sólo necesitaríamos
agregar este minuto que está antes de
donde empezamos y este minuto que está
después de donde terminamos
entonces serían 25 26 y 27
veamos
muy bien vamos a hacer otro
ahora nos preguntan la recta numérica
muestra cuando una lasaña empieza y
termina de hornear se otra vez el punto
verde indica cuándo empieza y el punto
rojo indica cuando termina a qué hora se
empezó a hornear la lasaña observamos
nuestra recta numérica y esta vez
podemos ver que este punto verde está
justo entre las 5 30 y las 6 de la tarde
lo cual son 15 minutos
claro veamos 5 35 45 las 6 de la tarde
las 6 15 las 6 30 muy bien
estas son 545 perfecto a las 5 con 45
minutos
a qué hora se terminó de hornear la
lasaña ahora el punto rojo está
exactamente en medio de las 6 30 y las 7
que corresponde a las 6 45 y ya lo
habíamos dicho cada una de estas marcas
equivale a 15 minutos 6 30 y 15 645 6 45
cuánto tiempo se horneó la lasaña
bueno pues podemos hacerlo de varias
maneras la respuesta nos la están
preguntando en minutos muy bien entonces
podríamos decir 15 minutos o sea aquí
hay 15 30 45 60
son 60 minutos y otra forma de pensarlo
podríamos decir que si empezó a las 545
y terminó a las 6 45 bueno la diferencia
es de una hora y una hora son 60 minutos
veamos muy bien hagamos otro
viviane empieza a pintar la cocina de su
abuelito a las 8 15 y termina 75 minutos
después cual de las rectas numéricas
mostradas debajo tiene un punto rojo
indicando cuando dif ya termina de
pintar a ver observemos con cuidado las
815 es cuando empieza libia las 815 esta
vamos a ver si aquí están las 8 y aquí
las 8 30 quiere decir que este punto que
está justo en medio es las 8 15 muy bien
y entonces aquí está a las 8 15 y luego
nos dicen que terminó 75 minutos después
muy bien 75 minutos después entonces
tenemos que partir de las 8 15 y sabemos
que cada uno de estos son 15 minutos
inicio aquí
30 45 60 75 muy bien o sea que la recta
numérica que indica cuando terminó de
pintar div
ya tiene que tener la marca roja en este
punto de las 9 30 y veamos cuál es la
que lo tiene esta segunda lo tiene muy
bien veamos nuestra respuesta muy bien
hagamos uno más
la recta numérica muestra cuando dina
empieza y termina de lavar su carro aquí
tenemos la recta numérica a qué hora
empezó a dina a lavar su carro bien pues
analicemos nuestra recta numérica vemos
que las marcas azules indican 320 325
330 y lo que quiere decir es que cada
una de las divisiones o marcas es de un
minuto
veamos 320 321 322 323 324 y 325 muy
bien y el punto verde está en las 324
muy bien 3 con 24 minutos a qué hora
terminó dina de lavar su carro pues
ahora el punto rojo está después de las
340 está 3 41 342 343 344 a las 3 44
terminó
en cuánto tiempo la bocina su carro
bueno habría varias maneras de hacerlo
podríamos decir que entre las marcas
azules hay cinco minutos porque está 325
330 335 340 o sea entre esta marca y
esta y 5 10 15 y ahora voy a contar las
que me faltan 16 17 18 19 y una que está
a la izquierda de donde empezamos 19 y
una son 20
otra forma de pensarlo es que si termino
a las 344 y empezó a las 324 vuelvo a la
diferencia en horas no hay ninguna pero
en minutos es 44 menos 24 pues son los
mismos 20 que contamos en la recta
numérica comprobemos nuestra respuesta
muy bien